dann ist es an der zeit deutschlands
fleißigste shitstorm produzenten zu
würdigen wir haben von dem ich spreche
boris palmer grüner bürgermeister von
tübingen hat uns mit seiner kritik an
einer wie er meint zu multikulturellen
werbung der deutschen bahn eine weitere
debatte über identität und rassismus
geschenkt die haben wir wirklich viel zu
selten finde ich warum macht der boris
das fragt sich ja auch serdar somuncu
fördersumme und schuh macht sich langsam
echt sorgen
ich mache mir langsam echt sorgen um
boris palmer inzwischen postet der mann
mehr quatsch als til schweiger nach der
fünfte flasche rotwein die bahn werbung
die palmers palme zum wedeln bringt was
stimmt denn daran nicht ich frage mich
warum von fünf personen die auf der
startseite der deutschen bahn abgebildet
sind keine so wie ich ohne
migrationshintergrund ist aha und ich
frage mich warum der bürgermeister von
thüringen zeit hat solche bescheuerten
fragen zu stellen
damit ist es offiziell in tübingen
passiert nichts
diese werbung ist wenn man genau
hinguckt total unlogisch hier
warum sollte ein sternekoch wie nelson
müller freiwillig ein sandwich aus dem
ece porträts chor fressen
er kannte keinen dieser promis alle
haben übrigens einen deutschen pass ich
würde sogar behaupten sie sind deutsche
jede firma soll doch selber entscheiden
mit welchen hat fressen sie wirkt oder
wollen wir jetzt in jeder werbung die
blonden und die fragmentierten
nachzählen wenn wir damit anfangen dann
frage ich warum gibt es in der tanke um
werbung eigentlich so wenig männer
ich fühle mich diskriminiert die bahn
verteidigt ihre kampagne mit nazan eckes
oder diesem hype finnischen rennfahrer
nico rosberg ist schon lange der bahn
verbunden als werbepartner er steht für
schnelligkeit warum macht er dann
werbung für die wahl der wusste raus
boris palmer ist jetzt beleidigt weil er
genau den shitstorm hat den er von
anfang an wollte er hat jetzt gepostet
dass er bis ende mai nichts mehr posten
will wissen sie was das bedeutet jetzt
da der zeit sich um tübingen zu kümmern
gott stehen hierbei die kleine stadt am
neckar
serdar somuncu machten sie nicht
[Applaus]
michael b schreibt auf facebook wilke du
bist der letzte arsch nur große fresse
ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es hart
auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir in
die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zwei oder hier auf
youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren